[Musique]
bon je vous remercie de nous rejoindre
sur tv soixante dix huit pour cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 politique et ce
mois ci nous parlerons de la campagne
des européennes sur fond de crise des
gilets jaunes et d'organisation du grand
débat national
elle les formations politiques tentent
de se faire entendre pour le scrutin qui
se déroulera en mai le point dans les
yvelines autre campagne est celle des
municipales les élections sont
programmées en 2020 et déjà
mantes-la-ville chacun se positionne la
seule ville d'île de france détenu par
le rassemblement national peut elle
basculer l certains parlent d'une union
de l'opposition la direction du parti
socialiste n'est pas forcément prête à
soutenir l'initiative sont au secrétaire
adjoint dans les yvelines sera en
plateau et puis à saint quentin en
yvelines coignard retrouve une vice
présidence un poste vacant depuis la
démission de jean-pierre sevestre ancien
édile de la commune et puis ils
reviendront aussi enfin d'édition sur le
départ du maire de l saint-cyr-l'ecole
fin février un départ surprise pour
préparer l'avenir
selon le principal intéressé à
l'actualité politique du moment c'est
donc ce grand débat national qui se
tient à travers toute la france nous
nous étions sur l'une des réunions
organisées en commun par les communes de
montigny le bretonneux et de guyancourt
l'animation était organisée par alexis
constantin professeur de droit à
l'université de versailles saint quentin
le reportage de nicolas landry un
amphithéâtre universitaire lieu du
savoir pour débattre de l'avenir du pays
voilà le cadre du grand débat national
commun à montigny le bretonneux et
guyancourt
environ 300 participants avec notamment
des propositions différentes autour des
finances et des services publics sur la
dépense publique qu'il faut la réduire
parce que aujourd'hui elle s'élève à peu
près 50 7% du pib et c'est anormalement
élevé déjà déjà le point d'indicé ans
encore est une bonne chose
les fonctionnaires travaillent dans des
conditions effectivement sur le terrain
c'est ça devient très très compliqué
mais par alan dans leur vie personnelle
aussi ça devient extrêmement compliqué
les quatre thématiques ont animé le
débat avec la participation de quelques
jeunes impliqués notamment sur les
questions de transition écologique
je suis là parce que je pense que c'est
intéressant de s'intéresser à
l'actualité politique et ne pas se
plaindre d'un côté de peut être entendu
par par les élites et et ne pas venir là
donc je viens pour ça on fait partie
d'une communauté de la cité on a besoin
de voix là de montrer qu'on est là les
jeunes bon c'est vrai on est censé être
beaucoup d'étudiants ce soir on voit
beaucoup de personnes entre guy nager
mais voilà pour faciliter l'organisation
de cet événement les villes de montigny
le bretonneux et guyancourt honte
oeuvrer en commun lu vs qu a demandé à
alexis constantin professeur de droit
d'orchestrer les échanges c'est d'animer
ce débat d'essayer de faire émerger les
arguments de chacun les idées les
questions les sentiments mais le tout
avec calme sérénité comme se doit dans
un débat au sein d'une démocratie il ya
des questions qui ont été posées il ya
des réflexions il ya des suggestions
d'organisation de réductions de dépenses
et tout depuis trois mois il ya quand
même énormément de manifestations qui se
sont passé et les gens avaient besoin de
s'exprimer aussi de pouvoir
effectivement dire ce qu'ils avaient sur
le coeur
ce qu'ils souhaitaient comme
modification des propositions aussi
parce que ce soit par exemple ya eu
énormément de propositions
le grand débat national doit se clôturer
le 15 mars prochain une synthèse des
idées doit être réalisée courant avril
le grand débat qui se poursuit donc
jusqu'à la mi mars les contributions des
uns et des autres vont se poursuivre
avant de recevoir le premier secrétaire
fédéral adjoint de la fédération
socialiste des yvelines
écoutez ses concitoyens venus participer
depuis plus d'un mois aux différentes
réunions à travers les yvelines
je vois les loyers les charges sont très
chers et les gens ils s'arrêtent même
pas sortir et sont toujours les gens
avec l'épreuve du duo avec nos bailleurs
et ce toujours avec des sons très banal
avec les règles des charges les les
loyers les isles arrête pas sur cher ils
n'auraient pas mais il faut des faux
faux les moyens c'est le pouvoir d'achat
aux mois pour moi c'est le pouvoir
d'achat sur priorité sur la dépense
publique qu'il faut la réduire
parce que
aujourd'hui elle c'est l'aide à peu près
50 7% du pib s est anormalement élevé
dont jeu
suppose qu'ils en baissant la dépense
publique on va baisser la dette publique
et par voie de conséquence baisser la
pression fiscale
je pense aussi qu'il faut arriver à
minimiser sinon annuler complètement la
mécanique de niches fiscales qui fait
qu'un sergent ou d'argent et
totalement à l'impôt sur le revenu est
ce qu'il faut bien comprendre qu'il ya
beaucoup de gens qui ne sont pas sujets
à la potion devenu mais qui sont jugées
fiables d'approché grandes fortunes et
que je pense qu'il ya quelques du hyatt
uche quelque part qui doit être corrigé
je reçois présent boris vernon bonjour
bon je vous remets secrétaire fédéral
adjoint de la fédération socialiste des
yvelines on a entendu plusieurs citoyens
qui participent à ces différentes
réunions du grand débat ce qui revient
le plus souvent c'est ce pouvoir d'achat
la fiscalité juste déjà pour vous faire
réagir sur ce qu'on vient d'entendre
est-ce qu'il faut revoir tout ce système
supprimer les niches comme par exemple
on a pu l'entendre nouveau parti sis
nous sommes assez pour effectivement
revoir un certain nombre de chose en son
temps jean marc ayrault avait proposé de
faire un grand une grande table rase de
tout notre système fiscal
malheureusement ça n'a pas pu aller au
bout pour différentes raisons mais on
est effectivement plutôt nous dans cette
dynamique là de réinterroger un certain
nombre de choses qui sont aujourd'hui
vous êtes en grand dans le cadre du
grand débat national auquel nous
participons également que nous
accompagnons au parti socialiste puisque
parti républicain nous estimons que
cette démarche était plutôt salutaire à
l'initiative du président de république
est organisée par le gouvernement
c'est la question que j'allais vous
poser parce que certains parlent de
campagne déguisée pour le président
macron d'autres justement salue cet
exercice intéressant aussi pour la
démocratie vous fait plutôt partie de
ceux là alors labrador une position
nuancée saisir comment on a le droit
d'être à la fois enthousiaste pour le
bel exercice démocratique que ce grand
débat national représente sur papier
c'est toujours bien que les six
constituent que nous considérons pu
s'exprimer et qu'ils puissent émettre
leurs idées
après on peut aussi être vigilant sur
les conditions d'exercice
de ce grand débat national le fait que
ce ne soit plus la qualité la commission
nationale du débat public qui soit
l'organisateur le garant de cette
démarche nous inquiète un petit peu
alors on fait partie du comité de suivi
mais voilà on a une vision sur ces
aspects nos militants sont les réunions
du grand débat devenir aussi à pouvoir
s'approprier ce que j'en dise
est-ce qu'on fasse notre analyse et à ce
qu'on vérifie que le gouvernement qui
est quand même à la manoeuvre sur cet
exercice restitue correctement
l'intégralité des sujets qui ont été
abordés par les français et notamment
puisque c'est ça qu'on entend beaucoup
et qu'on entendait dans vos reportages
les questions liées au pouvoir d'achat
et à la justice sociale et fiscale
vous avez participé à ces réunions est
ce que vous en avez organisé où vous
allez en organisées sur le département
on n'organise je prends le cas de ma
section mureaux organisera une réunion
du grand débat le samedi de mars au
matin je sais qu'il ya d'autres sections
dans le département qui font la même
chose et qu'ils s'impliquent tout
simplement dans celles qui sont déjà
organisées par les mairies des
associations d'élus locaux aussi souvent
qu'ils permettront d'avoir une certaine
forme de neutralité dans le débat voilà
où effectivement comme dans votre
reportage je voyais en souriant
quelques-uns de mes camarades d'une très
forte sur les images et qui participent
également à cet exercice
il ya de nombreuses propositions qui
ressortent de ces différents débats ré
indexation des retraites par exemple sur
l'inflation augmentation du smic à 1300
euros nets renationalisation des routes
suppression de la tva sur les produits
de première nécessité pour n'en citer
que quelques-unes de ces mesures
s'il ya des propositions qui retiennent
aussi votre attention alors oui d'autant
plus qu'il ya des propositions qu'on
avait fait bien avant que ce grand débat
national ne soit lancé quand la crise 10
g jona commencé à éclater les groupes
parlementaires socialistes ont déposé
une proposition de loi assez tôt à la
fin de l'année dernière avant même que
le débat nationaux ne soient initiées
par présent de répliques et dans la
profession à qui a été déposé un certain
nombre de mesures
condom qui sont défendues par nos
concitoyens dans les réunions je pense
notamment au rétablissement de l'usf
je pensais ce que vous venez dire à
savoir effectivement elle rien des
créations de des retraites sur
l'inflation au fait de réserver la
hausse de la csg pour les plus hautes
retraite voilà ce type de mesures qui
nous paraissent absolument indispensable
mais quand vous voyez la contestation
par contre qui perdure qui a durci aussi
avec des terribles parfois mêmes
souvent ces derniers jours on pourrait
parler aussi de l'antisémitisme
notamment mais on a aussi constaté des
églises dégrader sans fin sans faire
d'amalgamé sur tout ce qui s'est produit
on sent cette contestation forte cette
violence aussi en tant que responsable
politique vous la condamnez vous la
comprenez bien sûr qu on la condamne
bien sûr qu'on est au côté 1 des forces
de l'ordre dans cet exercice puisque ce
sont comme un peu qu'ils assurent
l'ordre républicain nous avons tous
besoin pour l'exercice de nos libertés
publiques et bien sûr que nous sommes
aussi pleinement partie prenante des
dénonciations des excès de tous bords
notamment antisémites dit puisque c'est
à l'invitation du parti socialiste que
le rassemblement contre l'antisémitisme
a eu lieu à paris et dans plein de
villes de france ces derniers jours
donc voilà on est effectivement dans
cette condamnation sans réserve des
violences après on est ce qu'on souhaite
que soit entendu la voix de la majorité
enfin ce qu'on estime être la voix de la
majorité à savoir l'appel à la justice
sociale qui est porté par une bonne
partie du mouvement et de manière
beaucoup plus apaisé qu'on a pu voir à
moi le débat qui est organisé et pour
autant il ya toujours des manifestations
si on exclut les débordements on
continue à exprimer cette colère dans la
rue tout à fait ce qu'il faudrait pas
réduire cette colère dans la rue et
participer plus au débat ou est-ce que
les deux sont pas incompatibles mais
encore une fois et l'exercice est
toujours compliqué savoir
qu'effectivement nous ne souhaite pas
aller dans des excès comme ce que la
majorité est en train de proposer à
savoir une loi dite anti casseurs mais
qu'il y ait une vraie loi de restriction
des libertés des libertés publiques et
quitte dans les mains d'autres majorités
aux valeurs - démocrate que celles qui
sont en place actuellement pour être un
vrai outil de contrôle anti démocratique
qui on revient sur cette campagne des
municipales on en a peu parlé avec ces
différentes propositions qui vont
forcément se retrouver ensuite dans les
programmes des différents candidats des
partis politiques les propositions
faites par les citoyens la campagne des
municipales ce ne sera qu'en 2020
elle sera importante pour le parti
socialiste après les différents échecs
et notamment aussi dans les yvelines on
va en parler plus en détail
vous vous préparez déjà assez municipal
bien sûr on s'y prépare on s'y prépare à
la mode socialiste savoir en parlant
programmé idée donc là en ce moment
notre fédération est en train de monter
plusieurs ateliers et un vrai travail de
réflexion pour déterminer les idées et
les les propositions qu'on défendra dans
le débat alors à savoir dans le débat
des municipales mais en amont aussi avec
nos partenaires nos partenaires de
gauche pour constituer des alliances
deux premiers tours à partir non on est
tous d'accord sur les projets pour les
villes du département
vous n'êtes pas prêts à toutes les
alliances un exemple mantes-la-ville la
seule commune d'ile-de-france qui est
dirigé par le rassemblement national
marine le pen ya même fait on verra en
images sa rentrée politique en septembre
dernier le candidat des républicains qui
est dans l'opposition aujourd'hui un
manque la ville se dit prêt à travailler
avec la gauche pour battre le maire du
rassemblement national il a même
réfléchi confié réfléchir à la création
d'une liste commune avec les anciennes
maire ps et divers gauche vous vous
dites non pas d'alliance alors toujours
la nuance est terrible avec un moment il
faut prendre une décision à mes rendez
vous exceptionnel sera pas rassuré venu
où cette décision elle est déjà clair
dans la tête
non en fait on est tout à fait d'accord
et on encourage même le travail qui a
lieu en ce moment entre opposition
qu'elle soit de gauche ou de droite
républicaine au sein du conseil
municipal demande puisque effectivement
face à la politique de casse et de deux
cas celui de la cohésion sociale
notamment mené par le maire il nous
apparaît important que les oppositions
et puis week-end soit dans un travail
commun donc ça nous l'accompagnons et
nous en sommes très heureux
nous disons non effectivement une
perspective d'alliance de premier tour
pour les municipales puisqu'un programme
puisque je vous disais tout à l'heure un
programme municipal ça se bat ça se base
sur des valeurs communes des
propositions en commun et on est bien
évident que des familles petit coup
valeurs aussi il peut
proche que les républicains et le parti
socialiste pourront difficilement même à
l'échelle locale bâtir un projet commun
ça nous paraît être un choix de raison
pour les manduellois aussi s'il est
important qu'ils aient des projets qui
soit clair cohérent et surtout qu'ils
puissent se mettre en oeuvre une fois
les élections passées
et ça nous paraît passer par des
majorités qu'ils soient elles aussi tout
à fait cohérentes entre elles notamment
au niveau des valeurs vous en avait
parlé avec ses ancien maire divers
gauche parti socialiste de cette commune
jacques chesnais notre notre premier
secrétaire fédéral a été en contact à la
fois et canvas est à la fois avec
monique brochot pour leur passer ce
message
c'est un dialogue qui est en cours elles
l'entendent très bien elles mêmes sont
des phases plus tôt qui sont
d'interrogations et sont aussi on est
très tôt par rapport à l'échéance
municipale
donc chacun réfléchisse les gens se
parlent entre eux c'est plutôt une bonne
chose mais voilà nous tenons à
réaffirmer d'entrée de jeu quels étaient
les lignes rouges que du côté des
socialistes des villes nous ne
souhaitions pas voir franchir et puisque
l'on parle de manque la ville syrie une
note le maire du rassemblement national
lui a laissé pour l'instant planer le
doute sur une nouvelle candidature en
2020 en revanche une association
baptisée nous mentent villois avec une
orientation politique de gauche vous
avez peut-être échanger avec eux ont eux
d'ores et déjà déclaré leur candidature
le reportage la campagne municipale et
élancé à mantes la ville comme une
importante pour le rassemblement
national le parti à la tête de la
municipalité avec son maire cyril note
face à cette majorité un collectif
citoyen baptisé nous mentent lillois
s'est constitué avec une sensibilité de
gauche
depuis 2014 et jusqu'à aujourd'hui on a
fait le constat douloureux d'une gestion
municipale de mantes la ville
catastrophique sur tous les sujets
toutes les prérogatives de la ville par
sa majorité actuelle front national et
face à ce constat là et face à cette
urgence et face aux autres urgences qui
sont les urgences environnementales les
urgences sociales d urgence démocratique
on a décidé nous habitants de mantes la
ville de prendre les devants et avec nos
voisins avec les habitants de la ville
de construire la ville de demain et pour
construire leur projet municipal
l'association souhaite faire participer
les citoyens pendant ces douze mois on
va utiliser chaque seconde pour
solliciter et faire participer la plus
nos voisins pour pour construire à la
fois les priorités et par rapport à ses
priorités la dégager les solutions qui
sont adaptées au contexte de mantes la
ville
parallèlement à cela un front
républicain pourrait voir le jour à
travers une union entre les républicains
et le parti socialiste
quant à cyril note il n'a pas encore
officialisé sa candidature
vous avez changé avec ses représentants
de gauche pas encore mais effectivement
moi je connais roma carbone au moins de
nom même si je pense que l'uimm côté
beaucoup
et effectivement c'est une ligne cette
citoyenne de gauche n'y a aucune raison
pour laquelle on ne discuterait pas avec
avec eux bien sûr faux ce soit d'un
commun accord mais au contraire on y est
largement très ouverte au dialogue alors
au delà de mantes-la-ville qu'elles sont
quels sont les objectifs du parti
socialiste dans ce scrutin municipal au
sein du parti socialiste y avait
beaucoup de remous au sein du parti
socialiste des yvelines
peut-être même encore plus avec le
départ de benoît hamon qui est lui à
fonds des générations
la responsable de l'époque sandrine
grands groupes qui l'a soutenue elle a
d'ailleurs quitté le parti exclu du
parti pour cette raison avec une
nouvelle direction qui s'est donc mise
en place aujourd'hui quelles sont les
priorités et quels sont les objectifs du
parti socialiste les priorités sont
celles que notre premier secrétaire
fédéral avait décidé il ya peu près
un an de ça sera déjà reconstruire la
maison commune puisque effectivement
vous l'évoquiez on a eu quand même
quelques dissensions dans le département
avec beaucoup de départs de jean cau
alors qu'on a regretté mais voilà une
bonne partie c'était leur choix donc que
nous on est on est resté sur nos valeurs
sur nos convictions et sur sur le parti
socialiste et donc nous sommes en phase
de reconstruction avec un programme pour
les municipales de redéfinition des
objectifs et c'est effectivement le
l'ordre un urgent c'est de se mettre en
ordre de bataille parce que derrière
nous au delà des questions d'appareil il
ya aussi des concitoyens qui attendent
d'avoir des mesures de progrès social
d'avoir enfin au concept la casse dans
un talent certain devine qu'on défende
les valeurs du service public et ça
c'est évidemment notre famille politique
qui est la plus à même de le faire
encore faut-il qu'elle soit en capacité
de présenter ses programmes et ses
propositions nos concitoyens mais d'ici
là il ya les européennes
la campagne vous arrivez à la mener
malgré tout mais cette manifestation
delhi les jaunes
ces contestations c'est compliqué que
effectivement le grand débat national
qui bien sûr occupe tout l'espace
médiatique pour autant oui nous sommes
en phase de préparation même si la
campagne très honnêtement devrait être
assez courte ce qui devrait laisser très
peu de place aux sujets européens
malheureusement du côté du parti
socialiste nous notre programme et il a
été arrêté l'an dernier nous connais nos
propositions et nous sommes toujours en
discussion là encore dans une volonté
d'alliance avec les forces de gauche dès
le premier tour selon discussions avec
nos partenaires etc pour l'instant ce
travail mais qu'est nationale n'a pas
encore abouti même si notre famille
politique est très très volontariste
pour essayer de faire déboucher cette
perspective notamment europe ecologie
les verts jadoul a dit claire et nette
il ne veut pas d'alliance tout à fait
yannick jadot est assez peu ouvert cette
perspective mais bon le temps fait
parfois bien les choses
merci morice berne on l'espère salle
bleue adjoint donc du parti socialiste
des yvelines d'être venu sur ce plateau
parler de ces différents sujets
d'actualité
merci à vous quant à nous nous
continuons à parler de ces européennes
avec debout la france la caravane de la
formation de nicolas dupont aignan qui
sillonnent le pays est passé par les
yvelines le 20 février dernier des états
pas possibles versailles rambouillet
pour rencontrer les habitants
vous le voyez sur ces photos elle debout
la france crédité de 7% dans les
sondages et puis du côté des
républicains la tête de liste elle
s'appelle françois xavier bellamy il est
élu à versailles il a le plein soutien
de laurent wauquiez les deux hommes ont
fait le tour du département
récemment aussi sont en mission de
reconquête un invité de marque pour la
mission reconstruction de la droite
laurent wauquiez président du parti les
républicains un déplacement à l'école
idec d'aubergenville des formations dans
l'industrie et des rencontres avec des
étudiants et des personnes en
réinsertion professionnelle là j'ai
changé quelqu'un qui était au rsa qui
avait repris une formation pour ensuite
déboucher vers un emploi à la fin il me
dit le problème c'est que la différence
entre ce que je gagne en travaillant et
ce que je gagne en restant chez moi
n'est pas très importante
bah ça c'est important de l'entente ce
déplacement dans les yvelines rentre
dans le cadre du tour de france engagée
par le président des républicains pour
recueillir les difficultés sur le
terrain et notamment dans ce bassin
industriel du nord du département un
territoire industriel qui subit de plein
fouet la concurrence internationale qui
se bat et qui veut rester un territoire
industriel et qui pour se faire à des
chefs d'entreprise des établissements
éducatifs comme celui là qui participe à
la compétitivité du territoire mission
reconstruction également dans la soirée
à versailles autour de la tête de liste
des républicains aux élections
européennes françois xavier bellamy au
début il ne faisait pas l'unanimité dans
son parti aujourd'hui les républicains
sont derrière lui bien sûr j'ai changé
avec gérard larcher j'ai eu l'occasion
de le voir de passer beaucoup de temps
avec lui il m'a redit à quel point
d'ailleurs il avait confiance dans le
fait que je pouvais apporter quelque
chose à cette liste il croyait que je
n'avais peut-être pas le poids politique
suffisant pour pouvoir être en tête de
liste et après tout c'est vrai que c'est
un pari et je suis prêt maintenant à
remporter ce défi
au delà du trio composé de françois
xavier bellamy d'agnès effréné d'arnaud
danjean
les républicains veulent porter une
certaine vision de l'europe
il faut absolument redonner sens à
l'europe parce que nous avons besoin
d'europe dans la mondialisation
mais nous avons besoin d'une europe
efficace d'une europe qui puisse agir
concrètement au service de nos
concitoyens
on est pour une europe
deux projets une robe de coopération
entre les pays la reconstruction passe
par les élections européennes le 26 mai
prochain un résultat pour confirmer la
victoire des républicains aux yvelinois
lors des sénatoriales en septembre 2010
est avec cinq sièges sur six remportée
ce choix de françois xavier bellamy qui
ne séduit pas donc toute la droite en
raison des positions anti mariage pour
tous ou encore anti ivg du professeur de
philosophie des cadres du parti comme
valérie pécresse et gérard larcher
expriment leurs réserves écoutez c'est
une personne que de grande valeur et
pour lequel j'ai beaucoup d'estimé et
d'amitié
mais ses positions sur un certain nombre
de sujets de société ne sont pas les
miennes et je ne veux pas qu'on pense
que les positions sur les sujets de
société de françois-xavier bellamy sont
celles de la droite française
je ne veux pas qu'on que les sujets de
sociétés viennent polluer notre campagne
européenne en tous les cas nous
attendons la suite de la lys donc
clairement je soutiendrai et
accompagnerez cette liste mais il est
vrai que
ce choix là n'était pas mon choix mais
je suis dans une famille politique je
suis aux côtés de la famille politique
un mot de la situation à saint quentin
en yvelines à l'agglomération didier
fischer intégrer l'équipe des
vice-présidents lors du dernier conseil
de février le nouveau maire de
coignières reprend le poste laissé
vacant par jean pierre seveste après sa
démission à la tête de la ville et donc
en tant que conseiller communautaire ne
l'écoutent je remercie bien le président
de me faire confiance pour cette
quinzième vice présidence on voit que la
représentation de coignières au sein de
la communauté d'agglomération a quelque
peu diminué quand même hein on avait une
vice-présidence en avait aussi un
conseiller enfin une conseillère
déléguée
on voit aujourd'hui on a plus qu une
vice-présidence ensuite au sein d'un
certain nombre d'organismes n'y figure
plus au sein d'un certain nombre de
commissions n'y figure plus donc il ya
quand même il ya quand même une
une inquiétude par rapport à cela alors
je comprends bien les logiques
politiques la majorité et la minorité
mais d'une certaine manière mais
habitant mérite quand même mieux il
l'avait annoncé ce serait son dernier
mandat à deux maires bernard de bains à
saint cyr l'école élu en 2006 a donc
démissionné
la républicaine sonia bros le remplace
elle a été désignée lors d'une séance
extraordinaire du conseil municipal le
21 février sa réaction au micro de
grégory canal et c'est un grand honneur
c'est beaucoup de travail j'en suis
totalement consciente mais surtout c'est
un cheminement qui a pris 10 ans et je
remercierai jamais assez monsieur de
bain de m'avoir ouvert les portes et de
m'avoir appris le métier de d'élus de
conseillère municipale puis ensuite
d'adjointe est aujourd'hui de mer c'est
la fin de ce set 8 politique on se
retrouve le mois prochain l'actualité
politique aussi à suivre au quotidien
dans le journal chaque jour du lundi au
jeudi à 18h et puis dans l'hebdo
également à 18h à bientôt
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le
[Musique]